[Música]
i
y se supone que ahí entró al escenario
hay fuegos artificiales toda la gente de
tepic se emociona hecha por raza blanc
los niños
se supone como están
no los oigo como están
que les quede claro bien es una palabra
fantasma bien es una palabra que no
existe bien es una palabra que no dice
ni madrid bien es una palabra que no
comunica nada es el problema de la
comunicación en las casas en méxico como
te fue en el trabajo mi amor bien
aquí en la casa muy bien a ti mi amor en
la escuela rebién a que bien
y nuevo nada no hubo intercambio de
información de emociones no hubo
absolutamente ninguna interacción con la
gente que tienes alrededor
vivimos como autómatas expresando cosas
que sentimos y a veces ni cuenta nos
damos de lo que sentimos agarre tomar
derecha a la derecha para derecha todo
el mundo agarre su mano derecha alias y
haga le así por favor esto quita lo
bruto acumulado del día haga llegar
alegre por aquello que haya acumulado
algo de alguien haga legales muy bien
mano izquierda
ahora voltea a ver algo y de al lado
para que veas cómo se ve moviendo la
mano muy bien ahora mueve la otra mano
la otra la otra mueve las dos las dos
dardos todo el mundo omar mi preparación
académica de primer grado de primaria me
impide hacer tu chingadera a nueva lama
nombre ahora mueve los hombros tantito
mueve los hombros tantito así las
caderas para un lado para el otro
imagínense lo que quieren
tienen una imaginación graciosa por lo
que veo
yo soy mexicano
y he tenido la fortuna la dicha la
oportunidad o la desgracia como ustedes
lo quieran llamar de viajar por toda
latinoamérica he viajado por
latinoamérica y haciendo algo yo no sé
hacer nada de verdad soy muy bruto lo
único que sé hacer es hablar en público
es lo único en mi casa cuando un foco se
descompone wey yo le hablo bonito o sea
no no no sé hacer nada mi única virtud
es comunicar pero esta virtud nunca fue
así yo era tartamudo cuando tenía 15
años de edad tata tata tata tartamudeaba
no podía articular una palabra sin que
me equivocara llegue con mi padre porque
en las orientaciones vocacionales te
dicen sueña sueña con lo que amas sueña
en grande que quieres ser mi padre
quería que yo fuera ingeniero pero si yo
era ingeniero o en lo mío no era ser
ingeniero y yo lleva la obra a la
construcción y para cometer un error
aprenda de la construcción desde abajo
mi hijo desde abajo y el buey me daba el
pico y la pala y yo me ensucia de tierra
yo tienen
a mí no le gustaba la tierra no no no
era lo que me gustaba que me quería
lavar las manos a cada rato mi papá se
asustaba decía éste tiene procedencia
sexual rara la ensucia la tiene no le
gusta la tierra y cuando mi padre me
pregunta omar el resto que quiere ser de
grande yo le digo papá
quiero ser como coco coco
como conferencista
mi papá se me quedó viendo
dice omar el esto
normales
como me dijo mi papá díganlo relájense
siéntense como me dijo
imagínate tu papá el que más te ama el
que más te apoya el que debe de echarte
porra
llego con mi madre la mujer que me trajo
al mundo la que me parió la que me cargó
la que me hizo aquí llego con ella le
digo mamá es que yo quiero ser como con
un poco un poco
sonrió inclinó la cabeza
[Música]
me agarró el cachete puso cara de mi
hijo está medio güey
y me dijo mi hijito lo que quieras en la
vida lo que quieras pero ser
conferencista no
yo emprendo mi primera conferencia la
primera plástica que tenía 16 años de
edad 16 invité a los amigos de mis
padres los amigos de mi madre
empresarios para que me contrataran
según yo los invité a un hotel y cobre
en aquella época eran cinco diez quince
pesos de boleto nada nada más por
cooperación 100 personas invité a mi
padre puso a su asistente para llamarle
a todos a decirles que era una broma de
mal gusto de su hijo mi primer evento
güey yo era la decana yo era el
organizador yo era el maestro de
ceremonias era todo y no fue nadie
nadie mi primer plática la di a sillas
vacías ya estaba en el hotel voy había
100 sillas yo había pegado una carta a
las 20 personas invitadas especiales
contándoles lo que iba a ser mi futuro
en esa carta les estaba contando que iba
a viajar por todo latinoamérica les
estaba contando que iba a ser autor de
libros de audiolibros y les estaba
contando mi vida y los estaba invitando
a ser partícipes del primer día
no hay nadie fue
yo di mi conferencia la primera
con los ojos cerrados
espere una hora para que el público
llegara no llegó nadie de mis ojos
y llorando di mi primer conferencia sólo
a las sillas
fue horrible pero fue muy poderoso
mientras descubrían las lágrimas yo me
hice una promesa nada ni nadie me roba
mi sueño yo me hice una qué
nada ni nadie me roba mi sueño qué
pasaría si la juventud mexicana qué
pasaría si los jóvenes mexicanos
tuvieran esta promesa en su cabeza qué
pasaría así como yo soy víctima de un
sistema educativo en donde con el
pretexto del amor y con el pretexto de
grandes padres y con el pretexto de
mandarte a buenos colegios yo fui
víctima de un sistema educativo que en
vez de apoyar mi sueño
mi sueño y me puse a estudiar qué puedo
hacer yo para crear un modelo un modelo
de pensamiento un modelo psicológico un
modelo educativo para que las nuevas
generaciones hay gente que está
preocupada porque méxico puede ser que
se haga socialista way para que méxico
se haga socialista necesitamos tres o
cuatro generaciones décadas 40 años de
meterles desde la primaria el socialismo
como cultura verdad que no se puede lo
teórico verdad que no se puede verdad
que el niño vende limonada verdad que tu
hijo ya quiere vender limonada para
ganar dinero país sea san blas verdad
que sí o sea ya quiere ya entiende el
negocio entiende el dinero entiende el
libre comercio lo traen en la sangre es
muy difícil modificar los hábitos
culturales en una década es imposible se
requieren dos tres cuatro décadas para
poder modificar los hábitos culturales
yo me puse a pensar cómo nos han educado
a nosotros los mexicanos y los latinos
este modelo lo he presentado en toda
latinoamérica más de 21 países siempre
que presentó este modelo la gente dice
omar se lo juro que no voy a volver a
educar a mi hijo igual
están listos están listos quiero hacerte
una pregunta te educaron para hacer
chingolo para ser [ __ ] para que te
educaron pregúntale al de al lado
pregunta en el de al lado usted que me
está viendo en casa señora también la
gente de ted que está ahí en youtube
dejen de vivir de emociones digitales
cabrones y vengan a un evento en vivo
para que vean lo que es esto para jugar
que es el aplauso venga
[Aplausos]
dedicaron educaron para cinco lobas de
[ __ ]
se dan cuenta que la gente que viene a
los eventos sentimos puros chingones se
dan cuenta yo me puse investigar será
que nos educaron para ser y me puse a
evaluar mi modelo de educación y el
modelo de educación latinoamericano
evalúen el suyo para ello hagamos un
viaje de nuestra infancia a retomar
agarra tu mano agarra tu dedo y el
cerebro tiene cinco años y el cerebro
tiene carlos hazlo engaña tu cerebro
wayne todo el mundo lo engaña engaña lo
tuvo por el amor de dios
es gratís tiene 5 años quieres una nieve
quieres un helado llegas con la única
fuente que tiene para obtener te todo lo
que quieres en tu vida tu madre o tu
padre llegas con tu madre o tu padre
cinco años de edad
mamá me compras una nieve fíjense
fíjense cómo le hizo mi madre para
ponerse de acuerdo con la suya fíjense
mamá
mamá me compras una nieve
omar ernesto ya te dije que deja de
estar lárgate a todo o te parto tú
[Aplausos]
y va a aplaudir aplauda venga suéltelo
omar a un niño que le digo todos los
días no todos los días no todos los días
no que estoy generando en el porque
tenemos millennials huevones que no
quieran hacer nada de la vida porque
tenemos gente que todo le molesta porque
tenemos gente que no quiere lograr nada
porque tenemos gente que ya está
desilusionada del mundo y no quiere
soñar en nada porque desde los 5 hasta
los 18 años les dijimos a todo que no
pobre niño y luego a los 18 porque no
sueña porque no eres líder porque no era
chico
sabes que el niño
segundo error que me di cuenta en la
educación educamos viendo los errores
educamos viéndole a la gente los errores
mira qué mal te vistes mira qué mal
caminas mira qué mar te portas mira como
tras esos zapatos hace apenas cinco años
que se los compre
yo quiero hacerte una pregunta tú crees
que diagnosticar el error sana
en psicología decimos el diagnóstico
cura y enferma el diagnóstico cura y
enferma que crees que le hace el
despertar mexicano
levántate que voy a llegar tarde siempre
lo mismo contigo anda lejos de la
fregada qatar que crees que hace ese
despertar en el niño es que lo hace
reafirmarse individualmente no te oigo
es que lo hace ser chingón es que lo
hace luchar por sus sueños crees que lo
hace sembrar una nueva huella de mica
que es una nueva huella médica
información neuronal nueva en tu cerebro
que pasa cuando en vez de diagnosticar
de manera negativa diagnostica de manera
positiva
omar dijo es muy impuntual pues dile
eres más puntual que ayer
mujeres levanten la mano cuenta que
ustedes quieren marido muy cariñoso
levanten la mano siempre las mujeres
levanten la mano más detallista aunque
venga con el levante la mano levantá
levanta la mano levante la mano muy bien
muy bien muy bien quiere un marido más
cariñoso cierto o falso no es algo pues
deja de decirle ya no me compras nada ya
no me amas ya no me quieres ya no te
importó ya se te olvidó el aniversario
me dejaste en visto
tres minutos tardaste en contestar de
que estabas haciendo cabra
hay la dentista
eso no funciona cuando el marido te
quiere dar un detalle abre la última
carpeta se acuerda ya no me compras nada
lleguen de la flor pase de marchante
lleven la flor a la fiera diez pesitos
jamás lleve le llevará la flor a la
piedra de apetito además el marido se
acuerda trae diez pesos le va bien va a
las pláticas de té se motiva a traer
dinero va a pagar la flor pero en eso se
acuerda ya no me compras nada ya no me
quieres ya dices que hacer
qué tengo que hacer para que mi marido
marc sea detallista conmigo pregúntame
todos los días en la mañana durante
siete días quién es el marido más tierno
que tengo yo
quién es el marido más detallista quién
me quiere tanto quién me da regalo quién
quién quién quién que quién aguanta más
de cinco minutos que quien quiere
omar que estoy haciendo con eso
programando el cerebro de tu marido
haciendo lo mismo que hacen las grandes
compañías haciendo lo mismo que hacen
los grandes publicistas programar la
mente de la masa para que compren un
producto que ni les gusta
haz lo mismo con la gente que amas
quieres que tu hijo sea más inteligente
dile comercio inteligente quieres que tu
hijo sea más chingón dile como eres
quieres que tu mujer sea más tierna dile
como eres tierna y lo que quiera amor es
lo negativo tercer error en la educación
mexicana nos educan comparándonos nos
comparan con la hermana nos comparan con
la tía nos comparan con la prima porque
no eres como fulanita hay hasta una
serie de televisión porque no eres una
niña normal agarra tu dedo agarra tu
dedo agarra todo de largo y de lado
todos tenemos derecho de ser distintos
white y se lo dice lo dice lo dice lo
dice lo dice lo dice lo dice usted que
se está viendo ahí en su casa usted
también tiene derecho de ser distinto
qué pasa cuando te educo comparando te
género baja autoestima cuando educas
comparando a alguien le genera falta de
identidad porque no le está reafirmando
lo que sí es le estás quitando algo que
no tiene y nos está haciendo sentir mal
porque no es como alguien y como él no
puede ni ser futbolista o ni ser
bailarina de ballet o ser cantante o ser
actor él no puede paren se le da a
hablar en público al pendiente es lo
único que se le da cuando tú comparas
las habilidades de uno con el otro en
vez de enaltecer lo que estás bajando su
autoestima y cuál es el principal
problema de las sociedades en
latinoamérica baja autoestima cierto no
te oigo cierto como incremento la
autoestima de un individuo omar como
incremento la autoestima de un individuo
y el simple enseñándole a que se amen
solo cómo le hago para hacer eso todo el
mundo te dice incremento en el alma es
tema pero nadie te enseña cómo te va el
truco habla contigo en voz alta
quieres autoestima habla contigo en voz
alta para que omar para que tu cerebro
programe tus cinco sentidos buena idea
mal idea
siguiente error de la comunicación
mexicana por la atención siguiente error
de la educación mexicana nos educan
metiéndonos miedo deba robar el policía
pobre que sólo yo estaba en el
aeropuerto esperando mi avión estaba con
mi maleta y había un niño atrás de mí yo
extrañaba la media docena y liz y
cariñitos al niño los niños son como los
perritos les haces cariño empiezo en
alrededor de ti un adulto mismo cariño
dios mío me hizo en el mundo este wey y
empezó a rodar a correr alrededor de mi
maleta la señora me volteaba a ver yo le
dije no hay problema déjelo el niño que
se descargue para que nos chin en el
avión
tengo 6
el niño corría alrededor de mi maleta
tira mi maleta en la señora llaves
tiraste la maleta el señor se va a
enojar el señor te va a llevar el señor
te va a llevar
yo señora le guste de padre o que se
haya hallado anda buscando papa cobre en
niños estamos constantemente
amenazándolos te voy a dejar aquí me voy
a ir te voy a dejar pobres niños vivimos
metiéndoles miedo y luego cuando tienen
una empresa y les da miedo pero porque
te da miedo mi hijo porque no importa
esta china ahí lo del gusano se ven
tendiente a bronx por qué no
buena idea o mala idea que hago más
reafirmar su individualidad te educa con
él si se educa viendo los positivos
educa reafirmando la individualidad de
tu gente educa en valor en valor eleva
el valor de un individuo tampoco
exageres y porque el niño ganó séptimo
lugar muy bien muy bien cabrón
esfuérzate para llegar al primero
segundo tercero también hay que ser
realistas porque si educamos
sobreprotegiendo el otro día me
preguntaban
que pensaba sobre la protección sobre la
sobreprotección conteste algo muy fuerte
a la señora no le gustó pero dije que la
sobreprotección a un ser humano es la
peor de las violaciones que le podemos
hacer
no lo estoy dejando ser
la peor de las violaciones pero el mundo
le va a doler que le duela zeus mi hijo
tenía el hábito de meter el dedo a las
terminales de la corriente eléctrica
mi señora decía hay que tapar las todas
le digo gorda que vuelva andar tapando
terminales de corriente eléctrica por
donde el niño ande o sea imagínate
adaptarle al mundo al chamaco que se dé
un toque de esos no que se dé un toque
y verás que se le va a olvidar algo y
volver a meter el dedo como crees que se
va a dar un poquito te va a quedar
pegado no tu método es muy nazi
y sra se fue con la mamá nos quedamos
todos en casa y se hijos terapias paseos
les digo quiere está hasta la madre
andar persiguiendo hacemos todo yo yo yo
yo yo yo yo quien lo quiere curar todo
yo yo yo yo yo le dicen a su mamá
cabrones y así les va a hacer bajamos
los fusibles de la casa no hay corriente
puse un alfiler en su terminal eléctrica
favorita y le dije zeus no metes el dedo
no metas el te deum ha terminado y ceuta
tenía un año entre caminando y gateando
nos ve que lo estábamos viendo el güey
meter ese pick up
no lloro de quedaras que el bueno yo no
le salió sangre de chupa ya
lo volteamos a ver le digo zeus
qué significa eso [ __ ] no estuvo y
papá
es un instinto el instinto se llama huir
del dolor y buscar el placer
omar como cesc y en mi familia mi mundo
mi negocio mi entorno va funcionando si
hay placer
si hay placer tu entorno está
funcionando así cuando llegas a tu casa
y placer tu entorno está funcionando y
cuando llegas a tu casa tus hijos corren
a ti tu entorno está funcionando si
cuando llegas a tu negocio la gente que
viene contigo tu entorno está
funcionando y cuando llegas a las
pizzerías la gente señor de que tu
entorno está funcionando y cuando tu
entorno tausif cuando vienes a un evento
de texto entorno está funcionando si hay
placer pero si llegas y huyen
si das una plática y la gente separa tu
entorno no está dolor placer si eres
placentero es un imán
si eres doloroso van a huir de ti buena
idea o mala idea y el último secreto que
se me hace muy perverso de las familias
muy perverso el modelo de educación
educamos recordándoles eternamente los
errores que han cometido ni creas que
olvido ni creas todavía me acuerdo
y sabes que el secreto más grande para
la felicidad
tiene que ver con un truco y este me lo
enseñó a una de mis más grandes maestras
mi mujer yo venía de españa de una gira
de conferencias venía muy cansado venía
harto físicamente emocionalmente tres
días de avión me tocó una tormenta vuelo
de madrid a barcelona de barcelona al
farr frankfurt de frankfurt nos mandaron
stuttgart hicieron un desmadre por toda
europa para llegar a mexico tarde tres
días en llegar a casa mi mujer fue por
mí al aeropuerto a mí no me gusta que
vayan por mí al aeropuerto no me gusta
tengo tres días de viaje no vengo viendo
bien no he comido no sean o no estoy de
humor levanten la mano cuántos de
ustedes cuando no come y cuando huele
mal no está de buen humor ciaron esto
levanta la mar y lo demás lo doy por
sentado levante la mano a levante la
mano la bandera mar yo estaba de mal
humor y llegó al aeropuerto y veo que
está allí esperándome en la salida mi
mujer por sus tacones su falda sus
piernas de ejercicio muy guapa parada
viéndome perfumada toda linda y que me
el cabrón
en vez de sentir una sorpresa de amor me
da coraje porque no me dejan llegar solo
porque no me dejas conectarme en el
transcurso del aeropuerto a la casa
llega por mí yo no me lavado los dientes
siento que me huele feo la boca huelo
mal tres días no he comido la de otro de
agua para al abuelo me le quiero echar
encima y no puedo ver a coraje me enojo
con ella me subo al carro venga
enseguida de ella vengo renegando cinco
minutos después me entra el psicólogo
que llevo dentro
le digo gorda perdóname disculpa la
verdad que vengo de españa la verdad que
tuve una gira muy pesada gorda de amo
discúlpame gracias por darme la sorpresa
y venir por mi perdón señora me agarra
la pierna la pierna
y me dice con una sonrisa divina me dice
gordito no te preocupes te perdoné desde
antes de salir de la casa
o sea la hija de su madre ya sabía que
iba a llegar [ __ ] y no le importó
y fue por mi eventual volado y cuando
estoy enojado con ella me dijo no te
preocupes ya te había perdonado qué es
eso de perdonar a crédito
qué es eso de perdonar en pequeños pagos
semanales ue que dota amigo amiga el
mayor poder del ser humano perdona
rápido perdona rápido es que mi mujer
perdona rápida es que mi hijo mi marido
los valles
perdona rápido entre más rápido perdonas
más fuerte es perdonar no es una
debilidad perdonar es un gran poder
omar y si quiero alcanzar algo más allá
de la felicidad momentánea y garantizar
me la felicidad para siempre que tengo
que hacer buena pregunta mala pregunta
perdona hoy el futuro
hoy te van a hacer daño casarse es que
te juegan la vida de vez en cuando
tener novia es que te hagan de pedo
emprender un proyecto es equivocarse
organizar un evento ted es meterse en
problemas
dar una conferencia es nervio yo tengo
dos horas queriendo hablar queriendo
hablar pónganme público
entonces su mar
si el futuro me va
en el futuro me espera algo de dolor y
ya lo sé
la mejor virtud para enfrentar el futuro
es perdonar hoy el futuro este es amar
en libertad
esto es amar con sabiduría y ese es el
mayor poder que podemos tener como
individuos porque nadie te puede ofender
a no ser que tú les des permiso respira
profundo
exhala
y yo he hecho este ejercicio en muchas
ciudades países lugares de latinoamérica
y es la última presentación de me
gustaría hacerlo con ustedes pero para
ello quiero pedirte que te pongas de pie
todo el mundo en pie ya estuvieron
calentando la silla mucho tiempo venga
todo el mundo de pie todo mundo de pie
todo mundo de pie y la gente que está en
la parte de atrás acérquese a esta parte
del escenario aquí hay tres metros venga
venga hacen los que quieran venga venga
acerquen se venga sin miedo venga venga
venga con copa es gratis wey venga venga
para acá no le van a cobrar venga para
hacer que se venga no les pasa nada es
el final es que empezó como un sueño y
tú está haciendo parte de la realidad
a jugar el aplauso no es para nosotros
los stickers wey nosotros
vivimos de esto es pan comido chorizo
con huevos de m2
pero sabe quiénes son los verdaderos
estrellas de esta noche sabes quiénes
son los que creyeron en ellos cuando
nadie creía en ellos sabes quiénes son
los que se partieron la madre y muchos
de ustedes son los familiares de ellos y
lo saben son los organizadores de este
evento sí este ex parque la loma te dejó
algo para tu proyecto de vida el aplauso
no es para nosotros los speakers
compadre el aplauso es para los
organizadores que son las verdaderas
estrellas por creer que los sueños son
posibles
[Música]